Stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt, dein Ivo, dein Ivo, mein Ivo, hallo, Abstand! Hallo, na ihr beiden, ihr werdet bestimmt nicht gemobbt, hallo, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufo, hinaus am Steuer sitzt der Stefan. Hallo Stefan.
Hi, das ist so ein unangenehmer Anti-Mobbing. Das Problem ist, dass du ihn noch weiter in die Welt trägst mit deiner Nacherzählung. Ja, ich wurde dafür verprügelt. Ich will, dass diese süssen kleinen Mädchen auch dafür verprügelt werden. Das ist Gerechtigkeit. Benedikt hat hier seine Töchter gezwungen,
mit vorgehaltener Faust hier diesen Anti-Mobbing-Tanz.
Das ist voll Cringe,
haben die bestimmt gesagt.
Kann sein, ja, ab irgendwann
einem gewissen Alter ist alles Cringe. Dein Niveau,
mein Niveau, hallo, Abstand
und dann aber noch Addendum,
komm Nase, wir gehen.
Das ist aber nur Addendum, das ist aber Addendum. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das muss man nicht machen, das ist DLC. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Man nimmt mit dem Finger so seine Nase, komm Nase, wir gehen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also Mobbing ist nicht mehr nötig, es gibt Abwehrmaßnahmen, effektive, und deswegen macht euch da keinegen. Ich kann das nicht mehr. Du bist komplett am Ende schon. Du bist völlig in nichts zusammengesagt. Für mich, es gibt so, ich habe ja den Gruseltober gemacht, alle wissen, das habe ich allen erzählt. Wir haben uns sehr gruselt. Da habe ich jeden Tag Horrorfilme geguckt und der absolut schlimmste Film war so ein Sozialhorrorfilm. So ein Film, wo es darum geht, wie so eine Familie, die mehr unangenehm ist und unangenehm Sachen macht, so eine andere Familie bei sich einlädt und ist alles ein bisschen weird. und es gibt keine Jumpscares, es gibt kein Monster, es gibt keinen, der in der Ecke mit einem Messer wartet oder sowas,
es gibt keine gruselige Maske. Und trotzdem war mein Laptop die ganze Zeit so halb zu. Oder meine Finger auf der Pause-Taste, weil ich erstmal durchatmen musste. Und es ist so, es ist irre, was es mit mir macht, aber so unangenehme Momente, so Cringe-Comedy oder sowas, oder diese Vorstellung, dass jemand diesen Tanz aufführt. Und manchmal habe ich das, da kann ich mir gut bildlich vorstellen, und ich muss in meinem Kopf auf Pause drücken, weil sich alles in mir umdreht. Und diese Vorstellung, dass sich jemand sagt, komm Nase, wir gehen. Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Das könnte Ari Aster geschrieben haben, diesen kurzen Text, das ist ganz, ganz furchtbar. Auf dem Weg hier zum Studio habe ich übrigens im Radio von Unheilig, Wir sind geboren um zu leben gehört. Okay. Und ich hatte Gänsehaut, weil mir das so unangenehm war. Ich habe mal ganz genau hingehört, was die da eigentlich singen. Was die da seit Jahrzehnten uns in die Ohren träufeln, was der, Achtung, der Graf da singt, der sich der Graf nennt von Unheilig und dieser Text ist ja das beschissenste, was deutsche Vokabeln aneinandergereiht jemals hervorgebracht haben. Das Schlimmste, was deutsche Sprache hier verbrochen hat. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wirklich, ist ganz, ganz furchtbar. Und dann lief es mir. Du musst aber erst noch sagen, wie der Film heisst, da kriegen wir ganz viele Fragen, und du musst uns zweitens auch noch ein paar Stellen rezitieren aus Unheilig, Die perfekte Welle. Oder wir, nee. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Film hieß. Ich muss, ich hab auch gerade... Du wirst das nachreichen, wir schreiben das in den Beschreibungstext, weil da wahrscheinlich Leute das wissen wollen, die wollen sich wurmen, die wollen sich in zusammenziehen wie eine Rosine, wollen die zusammengezogen in ihrem kleinen süssen Bettchen liegen, wenn sie sich mit dem Laptop da diese Filme, diese schrecklichen Filme angucken, wenn sie so richtig in sich zusammengehen, so komplett ausgetrocknet sind, wenn die gesamte Feuchtigkeit den Körper verlassen hat. Der wurde mir empfohlen von unserem lieben Freund und Kollegen Christian Huber. Der hat mir den irgendwann empfohlen. Bestimmt haben wir darüber gesprochen. Ich weiss es nur beim besten Willen nicht mehr. Wie gesagt, Gruseltower heißt wirklich für mich, jeden Tag gucke ich Horrorfilm. Das hast du komplett durchgezogen. Habe ich komplett durchgezogen. Ich sehe noch die Nachrichten, die ich geschrieben habe, der Film,
also ich habe mit dem Empfohlen geschaut und ich habe
danach noch geschrieben, um 0.15 Uhr,
der Film war der absolute Horror.
Nicht nur die letzte halbe Stunde,
alles ganz
baff.
Speak no evil.
Speak no evil. Wichtig ist, dass er den Original
guckt aus, glaube ich,
Dänemark und nicht den, das Hollywood Remake. Ach so, aber dann auf Deutsch, oder was? Oder hast du denn auf Dänisch geschaut? Mit Untertiteln, ja. Ah, okay. Ich denke, der ist grossenteils auf Englisch, weil es um ein holländisches, entweder geht es um ein, weiß ich nicht mehr genau, um ein dänisches Paar, was Holländer einlädt oder ein holländisches Paar, was Dän ein einlädt. Jedenfalls, du merkst, es gibt die Sprache bei jeder. Du bist auch nicht der beste Filmkritiker, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Du solltest nie herzlich willkommen bei die Filmanalyse. Heute Speak No Evil. Also, da gibt es dieses dänische, oder war es ein holländisches, wäre auch belgisch, ist ja egal. Jedenfalls sprechen die eine ganz andere Sprache. Ich meine, das war belgisch, aber wäre auch holländisch. Belg es ja gar nicht. Holländisch oder französisch war es nicht. Also es war auf jeden Fall immer Deine Zeit ist um, Stefan. Und wenn ihr den Film, dann schaut ihr nicht nur dann, nee, dann seht ihr wenn ihr nicht nur seht, dann schaut. Warte mal, dann guckt ihr, aber ihr seht nichts. Nee, ist ja egal, aber ihr weißt, wenn nicht schaut, ist blind. Ja, aber es ist auch egal für den Film, Florentin, dass du mich da so festnagelst, so unangenehm. Es geht darum, die sprechen die ganze Zeit Englisch, deswegen ist egal. Ah, okay. Also keine Audiodeskription, du konntest es komplett genießen. Kein Problem. Ich konnte es nicht genießen, weil es das schlimmste Film aller Zeiten ist. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, Sozialhorror ist mein blanker Horror. Also, ich habe wenig
Angst vor Dämonen, Aliens oder sonst was,
aber Sozialhorror,
da fängt es an. Ich sage ja immer
Erwachsenenhorror. Und damit meine
ich jetzt nicht irgendwie Gewalt
oder sowas, sondern wirklich so Steuererklärung.
WLAN ist aus im
ICE, die Steckdose
geht nicht im ICE, du musst den
zwei Typen, zwei Reihen vorher. Das ist alles kein Horror. Ich finde das schon Horror auf eine Art. Das ist auch Horror. Aber Horror ist für mich, ähm, weiß ich nicht, laut zu telefonieren, peinlich zu telefonieren. Also so, das gibt's im ICE reichlich. Ich weiß, aber so soziale Etikette zu missachten oder einfach nur, oder mein Niveau, dein Niveau,llo Abstand zu tanzen mit vollem Selbstbewusstsein. Das ist bleib' ein Horror. Konstantinfilm, falls ihr zuhört, ihr liked manchmal unsere Posts. Wirklich? Falls ihr zuhört, keine Ahnung, dann möchte ich pitchen, und zwar ICE als Horrorfilm. Ruheabteil als Horrorfilm und das Publikum wird erleichtert aufatmen, wenn der Zug am Ende des Films als Happy End mit 300 kmh gegen eine Wand fährt. Am Ende, es sind alle wütend auf diesem ECE und man sieht einfach so einen Drohnen-Shot von oben, wie dieser Zug einfach auf eine auch wirklich komplett normal dahingebaute Betonwand, die da einfach ist auf den Gleisen und der Zug fährt mit 300 kmh dagegen Schwarzbeet aus. Der neue Film von Ruben Östlund, den ich ja so mag, der von The Square oder Triangle of Sadness, diese tollen Filme ... Der hat jetzt ja einen neuen Film am Start, also der ist gerade fertig gedreht, glaube ich, The Entertainment System is Down, wo es darum gehen soll, wie auf dem längsten Flug auf der Erde das Entertainment System ausfällt. Und nicht nur das, also nicht nur kann sich niemand beschäftigen, sondern auch, die können auch nicht ihr Handy laden, weshalb irgendwann alle Handys zunehegegehen und sich niemand mehr beschäftigen kann in unserer Dopamin gefütterten Zeit. und sich dann alle, das hat er auch schon erzählt, es soll auch die erste Szene des Films sein, weil am Ende steht das Flugzeug ab. Und ich finde das eine super Idee, wenn man das überträgt, wie du gerade gesagt hast, auf den ICE. Weil wenn man so einen Flo-Tin-Will-Character hat, der im Ruhrabteil durchdreht, generell alle genervt sind von der Deutschen Bahn und dann, weiss ich nicht, es braucht ja nur, manchmal braucht es noch so, es klappt ja irgendwie immer. Am Ende bin ich von Hamburg immer noch nach Köln angekommen. Viel zu spät, Stundenverspätung, durchgeschwitzt, weil die Klimaanlage nicht funktioniert, was auch immer. Es fehlt noch ein Problem, wie zum Beispiel, und dann ist noch irgendwie Oberleitung kaputt. Und dann komme ich gar nicht mehr an und so. Und wenn man noch so ein Problem hat, ich glaube, dann würden alle durchdrehen. Zu dem Grad, dass es eine Gefährdung im Zug gibt. Ich glaube, das Nächste, was ich ja jemals am Genozid erlebt habe, war, als es beim Zug hieß, der Zug ist zu schwer, es müssen Leute aussteigen. Wo wirklich einfach dann sofort jegliches Learning aus der Weltgeschichte einfach über Bord geworfen wurde. Es sofort hieß, ne, ihr habt Sitzplatz, ihr könnt ja auch aussteigen. Wobei ich immer derjenige bin, der dann geht. Weil es hat man ja in U-Bahnen manchmal, dass so U-Bahnen so voll sind. Klar, dann kommen die recht schnell wieder, recht schnell Sternchen in Köln, inzwischen auch alle zwölf Minuten. Aber ja, ich meine, hier wird gerade, ja, ich finde, also das war früher anders. Okay, das tut mir auch leid. Tut mir sorry für den Kommentar, wenn du da leidest. Nee, das ist halt einfach scheiße. Dann haust du sowas einfach raus für den billigen Gag. Ja, aber nee, diese Flugzeugapokalypse, darauf wird man sich ja auch schon vorbereiten. Mir fällt leider dieses Wort nicht ein, irgendwie Coldslawing oder Colddogging, Rawdogging. Rawdogging. Ich muss es nur mal aussprechen, das ist mir eingefallen. Ja, so ist es, so ist es häufig. Wenn man es erstmal ausspricht, dann ist es einem wohl eingefallen. Dass du dir wirklich alles entzieht. Ein Rhetorik-Kurs. Das ist halt wirklich gut drauf. Dass du dir wirklich selber alles wegnimmst und einfach nur vor dich hin starrst den ganzen Flug als Beweis. Das ist sozusagen das gegen den Löwenkämpfen des modernen Lebens, dass du deine Mut und Ausdauer beweist, indem du nichts tust, indem du dich allem entziehst und das einfach als Beweis der Härte und wie sagt man? Nicht Ekstase, sondern Eremit. Ja, wir kommen gleich darauf zurück, wenn Plotin wieder beisinnig ist. Ich habe mein Wortlimit erreicht für heute. Ich muss jetzt extra Zahlen. Datenvolumen kaufen. Jedes Wort, das ich für heute noch nicht runtergeladen habe, muss ich extra kaufen. Da sind Wörter nicht drin, wie zum Beispiel. Ich habe jetzt so einen ganz billigen Billo-Handyvertrag mir geholt, wo ich jetzt immer Datenvolumen hinzubuchen muss, weil ich zu wenig habe.
Einer von uns.
Du warst lange im Luxusleben unterwegs, in deinem Elfenbeinschrein, und jetzt bist du endlich mal unten angekommen bei uns.
Ja, ich hatte lange so einen zu teuren Handyvertrag, wo ich aber nie Probleme mit hatte, ehrlich gesagt, außer finanzielle irgendwann.
Und jetzt habe ich so einen Billow-Handyvertrag bei so einem Drittanbieter.
Und das Problem ist, da muss ich jetzt immer Datenvolumen zuverkaufen, weil es irgendwann zu Neige geht. Und das ist immer diese Rechnerei. Ob es dann am Ende ist, wahrscheinlich immer noch billiger, aber es ist dann eins nerviger. Deswegen habe ich ja damals, als wir angefangen haben, vor mittlerweile zehn Jahren mit diesem Podcast, habe ich mich dafür eingesetzt, dass unsere Podcast-Folgen möglichst klein
sind. Wenig
Platz, wenig Speicherplatz.
Aber jetzt beschweren Sie alle, dass es zu leise ist.
Und ich habe nämlich damals gesagt...
Dezibel sind Datenprodukte.
Sind reinste Datenprodukte. Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Und deswegen reinste Energie.
Und deswegen habe ich damals gesagt, nein,
das ist ein Podcast, der hat nur ein Ideal.
Und das Ideal ist, solidarisch mit allen Leuten, die in diesen mobilen Datenvolumen Verträgen gefesselt und geknebelt sind. Und bis heute hat keine Folge über 20 Megabyte wirklich ganz runter geregelt, wirklich mit dem Hammer drauf, alles, was nicht sein muss, wird weggeschnitzt, damit die Folgen ganz klein sind. Und lasst euch eins sagen, dadurch sind wir ein sehr grüner Podcast, denn jedes ... Ja, auf eine Art, ja, gut, weiter, weiter, im weitesten Sinne. Nein, nicht im weitesten Sinne, im engsten fucking Sinne, weil, wenn ich jetzt hier reinschreie, ist das ein Peak in der Waveform, nicht nur verbraucht aus mehr Pixel. Und die sind ja begrenzt. Es ist auch mehr Kilobit in der Folge. Mehr Kilobit runtergeladen heißt, je lauter wir unsere Folgen machen, desto mehr müsst ihr laden, desto schneller müsst ihr euer Handy wieder laden, desto mehr... Im weitesten Sinne. Nein, im engsten Sinne, deswegen müsst ihr euer Handy häufiger laden. Ich mach das so eng. Und ihr müsst natürlich mehr Daten runterladen, was auch Akku kostet. Exakt, deswegen sind wir leiser. Klingen wir vielleicht schlechter als alle anderen Podcasts, wir sind vielleicht kürzer als alle anderen Podcasts, man kann es vielleicht kaum verstehen, wir sind leise, aber dafür haben wir euch über 400 Folgen gerechnet. Locker, locker. 30 Cent gespart. Locker 1,20 Euro, über 10 Jahre gespart. Wirklich. Locker, wirklich, kein Problem. Die habt ihr jetzt auf dem Konto. Schaut jetzt auf euer Konto. Schaut jetzt auf euer Konto. Schaut jetzt auf euer Konto. Schaut jetzt auf euer Konto. Und ihr habt im weitesten, im aller weitesten Sinne des Wortes Geld gespart. Könnt ihr jetzt Geld sparen? Könnt ihr richtig ausgeben? Ich habe diese Woche Geld ausgegeben, weil ich bin jetzt dabei, mein Geldeimer, die Erträge einzuheimen sind langsam. Ich bin noch nicht ganz so weit. Nächste Woche kann ich dir die Ergebnisse präsentieren. Weil ich musste leider, das tut mir auch im Herzen weh, ich musste jetzt leider Stück für Stück mein Geld wegbringen. Genau, hast du erzählt, super nervig. Wir wollen ja die große Überraschung geben. Richtig, ich werde es am Ende zusammenrechnen und alles aufdröseln. Das Schöne ist, für uns ist es die große Überraschung, die du dir gewünscht hast. Du selber hast jetzt nicht diesen einen Zettel, aber wir schon. Ich hätte lieber, Ich hätte lieber wirklich alles auf einmal, weil es ist ein Unterschied. Meine einzige Frage ist, sind wir vierstellig? Stefan. Stefan, wer bin ich denn? Ich weiß noch nicht, was das heißt. Stefan. Was? Du meinst zu froh oder zu wenig? Ach, das ist ja süss, Stefan. Sind wir fünfstellig? Ach, Stefan, das ist ja niedlich. Ach gut, du bist ja herzanalig. Siebenstellig. Siebenstellig. Darf ich dir drücken, Stefan? Achtstellig. Du bist ja so herzanalig. Du bist ja so süss. Neun Milliarden, du hast eine Milliarden, neun Milliarden Stellen? Ja. Ach, du bist ja süss. Und dann können wir das alles aufdröseln und dann haben wir es auch vor Augen. Weil zum Beispiel das längste Sandwich der Welt ist was anderes, wenn es halt in drei Teile geschnitten ist. Genauso viel Sandwich, aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob es ein langes ist oder, weil die Wurst ist nicht so lang. Eigentlich ist der Weltrekord für das längste Sandwich der Welt, und das sage ich seit Jahren, ist eigentlich nur das längste Brot der Welt. Du willst ja nicht einen Schinken kriegen, der zwei Kilometer lang ist. Es gibt ja kein Schwein, das so lang ist. Ja, aber es gibt ja so Formfleisch wie Fleischfrust oder so. Ja, aber ... Das gehst ja schon hin. Nein, nein, nein. Das ist ja im Grunde, und das ist ja mein Problem mit Guinness Buch der Rekorde, ist, dass ja die Rekorde sich beliebig multiplizieren lassen. Beispiel, sagen wir mal, du bist der Mensch, der am schnellsten rückwärts rennen kann. So, Weltrekord, 100 Meter, schnellste rückwärts. So, dann setzte dir Schwimmflügel auf und rennst es nochmal. Und dann bist du der schnellste, der rückwärts noch kann mit Schwümmflügel. Dann setzt du dir ein saurer Kostüm auf, setzt dich in ein Auto, was auch immer. Machst halt so andere Sachen. Und dann kannst du da an einem Nachmittag locker 200 Rekorde rausholen. Und dann muss der Guinness-Notar da erstens alles aufschreiben, alles und dann so. Das ist mein Problem. Du bist der schärfste Kritiker. Du stehst im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde als der schärfste Guinness-Buch der Rekorde-Kritiker. Rekord für die am meisten angezweifelten Rekorde. Weil, stell dir vor, du backst das längste Brot der Welt. Und dann kommt jemand zu dir und sagt, hey, komm mal, beleg's noch, komm mal her, schneid's auf, beleg's und hol dir auch noch längst ein Sandwich. Warum denn nicht? Salat, lachst du. Nein, das können wir nicht machen. Das können wir nicht machen. Das ganze Dorf hat zusammengelegt. Das ganze Dorf hat zusammengelegt. Ich lege noch eine Scheibe Käse oben drauf. Wir haben den Ofen zusammengebaut aus den alten Ruinen. Als uns das Stadtzentrum weggebombt wurde, haben wir die Steine genommen und den längsten Ofen der Welt gebaut. Herr Gergijew, hören Sie zu. Sie belegen das, dann sind Sie auch das längste Sandwich der Welt. Aber also, wir haben einen Rekord, wir können nichts machen. Machen Sie noch mehr Käse drauf, dann sind Sie das längste Sandwich mit Doppelkäse der Welt. Ja, und dann sollen wir noch einfach Käse oben drauf und nochmal überbacken oder was und neuer Rekord. Das längste Gratin der Welt. Oder so.
Ich finde, wenn man jetzt auf die Menschheitsgeschichte rückblickt
und sagt, im Grunde, Croc Monsieur, kannst du alles machen. Wenn man auf die Menschheitsgeschichte zurückschaut und sagt, wo ist es gekippt? Wo ist es, wo ist es, wo ist es, wo ist es, wo ist es, wo ist es, Der letzte Kippe, bei der
vorsichtigen Kippe. Dann war es wirklich Ramses.
Nach Ramses.
Nee, nee, nee. Ich glaube, wir haben es
aber ich finde, wir haben es da noch ein paar Jahrhunderte
gepackt. Kippen, bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl bl holy shit. Und dann hat man gesagt, so, und jetzt nehmen wir das überbackene Laugenbrötchen und belegen es noch. Und da ist der Punkt, wo ich sage, stopp, hier kippt's. Das ist zu viel. Das habe ich gesehen. Weil du kommst bei diesem überbackenen Laugenbrötchen, ich bin bei Ramses, bei Ramses, nach Ramses, ich meine den zweiten, klar, nach Ramses des zweiten. Da ging's bergab. Da hatten alle Wohlstand, da ging's allen gut und das nicht nur... Wir reden nicht, da ging's allen gut, die hatten Sklaven, das war ein Pyramidensystem, das war... Pyramidensystem. Die Kanzler nicht einfach... Es sieht wie eine Pyramide, es ist kein Pyramidensystem. Naja, warum sieht's aus wie eine Pyramide? Das war der Ringsang. Also, da ging's allen gut. Herr Merz, Sie können in der Kanzlerdebatte nicht bei jeder Frage ziehen. Bitte. Ja, da kommen noch, mit Merz kommen noch Zeiten auf uns zu. Da sage ich dir aber hier vorneweg. Arbeite schon mal an deiner Merz-Imitationen. Podcast-Ufo, der Stammtisch. Es liegt Unterrubrik, wo wir so Sachen sagen wie, also unter März, also da wird es unter die Sachen ungemütlich. Blackrock auf Patreon. Sind aktuell 200 Folgen, das Podcast-Ufo, der Stammtisch. Also, Ramses hat das, und ich war in der Ausstellung nämlich jetzt, deswegen bin ich vielleicht noch ein bisschen in der Ramses-Phase drin. Könnte es schon sein. Meinst du wirklich, dass du jetzt das objektiv beurteilen kannst? Nein, nein, nein. Wenn du in deinem Leben eine Ausstellung warst. Aber wann war jemals was geil, wenn jemand etwas objektiv beobachtet hat? Stimmt. Es ist immer nur geiler, wenn man es reindickt und so. Und dann sieht man auch schneller, wenn es scheiße ist. Aber ich habe gesehen, Ramses hat die Leute in den Wohlstand geführt. Und das nicht nur, ich rede nicht von unseren kleinen Dimensionchen hier, mit zehn Jahren Wohlstand ging es nochmal gut, nein. 200 Jahre, 300 Jahre, wir reden von, also das ist wirklich eine, die Ägypter sind krass, wie lang die am Start waren und es denen gut ging. Ja, aber was heißt gut gehen, die hatten auch Sklaven, die hatten auch ... Blablabla.
Ist insane, wie lange es denen gut ging. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber kann es nicht sein, dass eher Leute, die Ägypten cool finden, sich damit auseinandersetzen und dann diese Hieroglyphen, die ja relativ bedeutungsoffen sind, vielleicht eher so interpretieren? Ist der Buchstabe A bedeutungsoffen? Nein, aber wenn da einfach Twisted Flags und
Eye of Horrors an seiner Wand
sind, ich könnte die noch vier
weitere nennen, dann
kannst du das so ein bisschen offen für die Interpretationen.
Ist dafür, dass die ägyptische Zeit war
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie viele Tausend Jahre das
Sternchen, ich weiß es nicht.
500 Jahre, boah, ja, 600.
Also wie lange, super lange war die am Start, aber die Art Direction
war so krass
stromlinienkörnig, geradeaus
eins zu eins.
Wir haben alle,
wenn ich sage, altes Ägypten, wir haben alle
die Malereien im Kopf, wir haben alle diese
langen Fingerchen, dann diese Leute, die so
immer im Profil stehen, Tierköpfe haben,
die auch so versetzt hintereinander, gleich gross sind.
Wir alle walk like an Egyptian, wir haben alle im Kopf, wie die Malereien sind. Die Bilder, nehmen wir nicht den einen Künstler, es ist ja nicht so, dass die den einen Künstler haben, wie zum Beispiel Leonardo da Vinci eine Epoche geprägt hat. Wir wissen nicht, wer das gemalt hat. Das waren Millionen von Künstlern, Künstlerinnen, die das gemalt haben. Und das ist alles gleich. Die Art Direction war insane. Aber war wirklich damals das Kunsthandwerk homogener als heute? Ja. Weil wenn du heute hast, du ja tausend verschiedene Stile parallel. Und glaubst du wirklich, im Mittelalter gab es einfach nur einen Stil. Im Mittelalter redet wirklich niemand. Als wirklich antikes Ägypten. Jeder, der ein Bild gemalt hat, hat exakt gleich gemalt. Da gab es nicht Rebellen, da gab es nicht Graffiti, da gab es nicht Street Art, die irgendwie da ausgebrochen sind oder so. Nein. Die haben wirklich exakt alle genau gleich gearbeitet. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Okay. Warum? Warum war das damals so homogen? Keine Ahnung, weil die, ich sag mal, die Hierarchien waren recht klar. Es gab sehr klare Hierarchien. Also nur ein Typ
hatte so viel Geld, dass er sich überhaupt Kunst leisten
konnte und dessen Geschmack war dann halt einfach der
aktuelle Stil. Und dann, was
es fiel so ein bisschen unter den Teppich zu sehr
bei dieser Ramses-Ausstellung, der wurde sehr vergöttert,
es fiel mir ein bisschen zu sehr
unter den Teppich, dass er
überall seinen Namen draufgeschrieben hat.
Auch auf so Bauwerken,
wonach herauskam, dass sie schon viel älter sind. Hat er einfach so draufschreiben lassen. Auch in Let It Be, da hat er gesagt, das ist von mir. Und dann auch sehr lustig, tragisch, in Abu Simbel. Ja, die ist ja umgezogen. Genau, aber da gibt es ja diesen großen Tempel in den Stein gehauen. Sim da sind ja diese vier Statuen und dann hieß es die ganze Zeit, noch nie hat jemand so eine große Statue für seine Frau gebaut. Noch nie war eine Frau im alten Ägypten so feier, bla bla bla bla. Und er wurde als so fortschrittlicher Feminist dargestellt. Da habe ich genau geguckt und die vier Statuen, die man sieht, diese riesigen, sind alle eher. Das sind so vier. Und du bist der Erste, dem das auffällt? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist, es wurde jetzt nicht explizit gesagt bei dieser Erklärung, das ist wohl allgemein bekannt. Ich habe mir die Augen geguckt und gedacht, das gibt es ja hier, sind alles eher. Und die Frau war in so einem Nebentempel oder irgendwie war so gross wie seine Wade oder sowas. Aber das war so super krass. Also deswegen, ich sag Ramses den Zweiten mit Vorsicht genießen. Ja, also für meine Grabunterkunft brauchen wir auf jeden Fall eine Statue. Okay, okay, alles klar. Auf jeden Fall eine grosse Statue. Herr Ramses, wenn die Frage erlaubt ist, wie gross?
Vierzig Meter gross.
Okay, vierzig Meter sind ...
Und dann, was brauchen wir noch?
Wie viele Ellen?
Das sind 120 Ellen.
So, dann was brauchen wir noch?
Was wird denn gern genommen?
Also das Volk leidet und hat Hunger und es gibt Sklaven dann machen wir doch einfach noch eine Statue von mir, okay? mal zwei mal zwei Statue die erste ist ja schon recht groß genau so groß, auch 120 Ellen und dann noch vielleicht so mit Löwen oder Mosaiken. Fürs Volk irgendwie, also Steuererlassungen oder irgendwie. Oder es gibt noch recht viele Sklaven, das wäre irgendwie schön, wenn die alle. Oder, pass auf, andere Idee, noch eine dritte Statue von mir. Okay, alles klar. Dreimal. Jetzt gibt er ja schon zwei. Genau, noch mal eine. Genauso groß. Und dann hatte ich noch überlegt, vielleicht noch mit so einem ... Ja. Ja, oder so ein Mosaik. Okay, Mosaik. Wir können auch aus Mosaik die Statue machen. Ich bin immer noch für eine Statue, das ist irgendwie klarer, das ist irgendwie schöner. Ja, geil, finde ich geil. Oder halt vier, weil ich gerade dran denke, viermal ich. Okay. Viermal ich. Sie. Ja, viermal ich. Wir können auch einmal sie und dann irgendwie ihr Vater oder Vorfahren. Ich finde, wir hatten jetzt eigentlich einen guten Stand erreicht. Man muss jetzt nicht überdenken. Ich glaube, wir müssen das jetzt echt nicht zerdenken. Wir haben jetzt eigentlich ... Ich meine, die Frage ist eher, haben wir es nicht schon zerdacht? Nee, ich finde, wir waren an einem guten Punkt. Ich finde, wir waren an einem Megapunkt bei einer Statur. Dann mach das mal. Und ich werde in der Zeit mich mit Milch... Haben wir es nicht zerdacht? Ich finde, wir sind gerade im Begriff, es zu zerdenken. Ich würde sagen, du baust das mal und ich leg mich jetzt in eine riesige Wanne voll Milch.
Okay?
Machen wir es so.
Das ist doch ein guter Punkt.
Wer ist mit vier Wannen Milch?
Warum legen sie sich nicht in vier Wannen Milch?
Da denkt doch jemand mit.
Dankeschön, wunderbar.
So, ich finde, das ist doch ein guter Schlusspunkt.
Bring die Kühe!
Ramses, Schmamses.
Bis mal so eine Badewanne voller Milch ist.
Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei, ei, ei.
Ramses. Ramses, ne?
Ramses, Ramses.
Ramses, Ramses, Ramses, Ramses, Ramses.
So, und jetzt sind wir nämlich in den Comedy-Clubs
in alten Ägypten, wo die
Leute verzweifelt versuchen, Wortspiele zu machen, ohne geköpft zu werden. Ramses Ramses. Nette Wortspiele, eine nette Satire. Ist natürlich leichter als Tutanchamun. Also da, als die Tutanchamun an die Macht kam, da hatten die Satire Leute aber ... Tutanch was denn nun? Tutanch was denn nun? Ja, ähm, tut den Armen gut.
Tut er nicht Armut.
Ja, genau.
Du sagst es.
Du nimmst kein Blatt vor den Mund.
Das war so der damalige Böhmermann,
der so, tut er nicht Armut.
Hashtag tut er nicht Armut.
Der spricht die Dinge an, die andere nicht trauen.
Immer mit diesen Fächeln.
Fächern. Fächern. Wie, das ist der Problem jetzt mit den Fächern. Ist heiß gewesen. Ja, aber dann zieh um. Wie? Also sorry, ja gut, die anderen machen Feuer, ne? Ja gut. Es ist nirgendwo, und das unterstützt ja auch meine These, die Temperatur ist nirgendwo richtig geil. Das stimmt, das ist ein guter, ja. Gut, es gibt natürlich Extreme, wenn du im ewigen Eis lebst, denkt man sich auch, wann ist denn da mal ein guter Tag? Genau. Also ich verstehe schon, dass nicht jeder Tag des Jahres gut sein kann, aber ich will schon wohl leben, wo ein ordentlicher Teil in Ordnung ist. Gab es mal das Gespräch, dass die Inuit sagen, wollen wir nicht alle umziehen, einfach weg von der Kälte? Vor allem, weil wir kommen ja her. Ich friere seit 80 Jahren. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Das Ding ist, wollen wir nicht weg. Wo wir herkommen, muss es ja per Definition wärmer gewesen sein. Also es ist ja wirklich arschkalt hier. Hier ist eisig, ich finde es eisig kalt. Gut, dass du das mal sagst. Ja, ja, ja. Seit 60 Jahren denke ich mir, es ist eisig kalt. Das ist ein gewisses Tabu. Wir reden da nicht oft genug drüber. Wir haben 40 Worte für Schnee und keins für kalt. Für arschenkalt. Klirr kalt. Ja, da sagen wir sowas wie arschkalt oder eisig. Ja, ja, ja. Oder Affen, mega affenröhrig. Saukalt. Saukalt. Ja, saukalt. Aber Schlittschuh fahren. Ja, aber nee, komm, wir ziehen einfach um jetzt warm. Und dann sind sie nämlich runtergegangen und wurden zu Ägyptern, wie wir sie heute kennen. Richtig, und waren froh. Und waren dankbar für den Nil. Bis da mal jemand sagt, es ist hier, ich gehe ein, es ist eine Bullenhitze. Aber aus dem Nichts, so 200 Jahre Familiengeschichte und einer sagt so, boah, ich schwitz mich hier tot,
ey, Alter. Ich schwitz
kaputt. Ich schwitz mich hier, ich
zerfliesse gleich, boah.
Jetzt, wo du es ansprichst.
Von einer Saukälte in die
Bullenhitze.
Ich möchte einfach
das Ding. Und vor allem, die haben ja den
Sonnengott angebetet, die Trottel, also
gar nicht böse gemeint. Ra, Re, Ra, sowas, sowas, irgendwer Osiris, Anubis, was da ist. Die hat zurückgerichtet. Ra, Re, Ra, Ra. Erstmal perfekt. Aber da bleibt man ... Manchmal bleibt beim ersten Gedanken, erstes Bauchgefühl. Wenn so fucking heiß ist, dann betet doch nicht die Sonne an, du Depp, oder? Wir haben die Sonne angebetet, um zu sagen, moderat. Meinst du, die haben geopfert, damit die gesagt moderat, rat. Bisschen runter. Hier ist ein Opfer, ein bisschen runter. Vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Abstand. Gehen wir einen vielleicht einen Schritt noch zurück, die liebe Sonne. Du rückst uns auf die P gehen, um zu merken, wie schön es eigentlich ist. Genau, Big Picture. Oft sind Bilder ja schöner, wenn man einen Schritt weg geht und es in Gänze sieht. Mal als Idee. Man hat für jedes Kalbsopfer hat man einen so, nur als Idee hier gerade. Hier, überleg mal. Überleg mal, ob die Dürre
sein muss.
Sind die wirtschaftlich stärksten
Räume der Erde
die, wo die Temperatur
am moderatesten ist?
Ich glaube, es hängt an vielen verschiedenen Faktoren.
Sind die wirtschaftlich stärksten, ich meine GDP per Kapital am höchsten, wo die Temperatur am moderatesten ist? Ich rede von BIP pro Cop. Ja, ich we weiß nicht, was ist in China
so für Temperaturen? Mongolei
so früher, wo es
heiß war, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, was weiß man denn nicht, wie früher die Temperatur
war, am Nil-Delta.
Ich glaube, hat natürlich auch was mit Wasseranbindungen zu tun,
ne, Infrastruktur, Goldreserven
und so, ne. Ja, die Antwort
langweilig. Das ist natürlich schwierig,
aber ich sag mal ja.
Okay, okay.
Ich sag mal ja, ich lass mich mal festnageln.
Ich bin mal komplett festgenagelt.
Ja, lassen Sie sich festnageln.
Ich bin, komm, ich hab gute Laune, ich lass mich heute mal festnageln.
Sehr schön. Einfach mal, ja? Warum denn nicht?
Wenn du so einen Computer hättest, den du alles fragen könntest,
den du richtig festnageln kannst auf alles,
den du so sagen kannst, was war der Tag, wo ich am meisten Leute zum Frühling gemacht habe oder was auch immer, habe ich mal an dem Tag, war ich einem Promi, einem Wälzler mal ganz nah. So kannst du einen Computer alles persönliche fragen. Was würdest du denn fragen? Wie viel Liter Schweiss habe ich schon geschwitzt in meinem Leben?
Drei Tonnen.
Drei Tonnen!
Wo sind die jetzt?
Sie haben noch drei Fragen. Ich weiss.
Weil sie fragen, wohin die jetzt sind.
Grösstenteils verdunstet.
Wie viele Socken hatte ich in meinem Leben schon an? Sie können wirklich spannende Fragen stellen. 13.400. Okay, meine letzte Frage. Bist du ein fucking dummer kleiner Dreckscomputer? Nein. Gut, dann bin ich zufrieden. Du hast vier Fragen, das hattest du eigentlich. Nö. Willst du schon gehen? Wir standen nicht für fünf Stunden an. In der Bullenhitze draußen standen wir ja an für diesen Computer. Es war so heiß, ich hatte keine Zeit, mir was zu überlegen. Was macht denn eigentlich der Genie, wenn du die letzte Frage, den letzten Wunsch nicht formulierst? Dann ist der immer gebunden, dann ist der immer, dann ist der nie erlöst oder so, dann bleibt der immer noch in der Nähe. Ich nagel mich mal darauf fest, ich würde sagen, ja, er ist dann an dir gebunden. Den kannst du dann ja quasi zum Sklaven machen. Ja. Und wenn du dem sagst, so räum mal meine Küche auf, aber das ist also jetzt nicht als Wunsch, sondern als Befehl, also kann der Sachen machen oder kannst du dann Kaffeetasse drauf abstellen? Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, der ist an diese Wunschscheisse gebunden. Diese Wunschkacke. Dieser Wunschbullshit, auf den die sich mal haben festlageln lassen, ne?
Ja, ich glaube das schon.
Boah, ich wüsste so viel Freien, die ich stellen würde.
So Fakten, einfach Statistik.
So wie viel Prozent aller Zwiebeln, die ich je gekocht habe, waren on point.
Also so genäht, so wirklich so richtig, so richtig auf den Punkt. Drei. Drei Prozent? Drei Zwiebeln. Drei Zwiebeln. Wow. Fuck, ey, drei Zwiebeln. Das ist ein komplettes Leben, ne? Das ist einfach drei, ich hab wirklich mal eine Banane gegessen, die war excellent, die war besser geht's nicht. Nie wieder besser gegessen. Ist das Ihre Frage? Nee, nee, nee, ich mein nur. Und die war wirklich, weil die hab ich noch gegessen und dann bin ich, die war im Büro. Entschuldigung, Sie wollen sich wieder noch eine Frage stellen, weil ich stehe ja auch schon lange ab. Ich weiss, ich weiss, ich weiss. Ich meine, es wird eine Frage, ich muss nur hinleiten. Und da habe ich, da lagen noch zwei Bananen. Das ist so ein Sozialhorror, den ich dachte. Das ist so was Schlimmes. Oh, nee. Ich war vor mir auf der Rolltreppe vor so eine sehr mysteriöse Gestalt, so ein langer Ledermantel, so ein irre langer Ledermantel. Und nicht nur das, sondern der war so in Schichten. Das war so irre, weil der war so, es war so ein Schichtledermantel, der immer länger wurde, je näher er dem Körper. Je näher die Schicht dem Körper war, desto länger wurde es. Versteht ihr? Was? Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es anders beschreiben soll. Wie so ein Gürteltier, so überlappend. Weird, weird. Es sah so aus wie so eine Rüstung. Je näher es dem Körper kommt, desto länger. Länger ist er. Genau, es waren so Schichten an seinem Rücken hoch. Und dann so alles, es wirkte so mächtig. Da hat er so einen Hut gehabt, auch so ein, alles war weird an dieser Gestalt. Und er war genau vor mir auf der Rolltreppe. Und er wirkte so unweltlich, also er wirkte so, nicht irdisch, er wirkte wie über den Dingen schwebend. Und dann ist er leider genau stehen geblieben oben an der Rolltreppe. Und ich so, sie müssen schon weitergehen. Also, sorry. Also nichts, und ich fand das so krass, wie seine Persönlichkeit und sein Outfit haben nicht zueinander gepasst. Und das ist so spannend immer für mich zu sehen. Maximaler Autoritätsverlust. Du musst doch, wenn du einen fucking Ledermantel dieser Art trägst, dann sei aufmerksam. Oder sei, benutze keine Rolltreppe, fahr nicht zu. Deswegen habe ich Angst vor verschiedener Kleidung. Ich habe meinen Gänsepulli, kann ich nicht anziehen, weil ich mir immer denke, die Leute erwarten eine gewisse Art des Verhaltens dann von mir. Du hast letzte Woche von deinem Gänsepulli erzählt. Genau, bis heute hatte ich ihn nicht an. Ich traue mich noch nicht.
Und deswegen denke ich mir,
okay, die Leute würden was von mir erwarten.
Aber ich fand das eine richtig geile
Idee, was du gerade gesagt hast. Wann war
ich einem Star jemals in meinem Leben
am nächsten? Das ist doch einfach
eine fucking App. Weil
die App weiss, wo du bist.
Und dann
musst du nur in die App sämtliche
Daten reinspeisen, wo Promis
Vielen Dank. eine fucking App, weil die App weiss, wo du bist und dann musst du nur in die App sämtliche Daten reinspeisen, wo Promis jemals in ihrem Leben waren. Jennifer Lawrence, Oscar-Verleihung, Berlinale, hier wurde sie gesehen. Jürgen Trittin. Jürgen Trittin war hier Bärnschelzimmer gesucht, hat hier gegraben, hat hier getaucht. Du hast natürlich nur die öffentlich zugänglichen Daten, klar, aber das reicht dir wahrscheinlich auch, weil die werden jetzt nicht ständig rumvibrieren. Du weißt doch nicht, wo gerade Paris Hilton ist. Ja, auf Instagram, die wird wahrscheinlich in L.A. Man müsste es halt den Prominenten sehr schmackhaft machen, dass sie den Standort mit dieser App teilen. Ja, halt so ein Jahr zurück, dass sie halt so ihre Daten teilen von vor einem Jahr. Man kann ja sagen, als App-Anbieter, die heißt das Podcast-UFO, kann man ja den Leuten, also den Prominenten sagen, wir benutzen unseren Standort die ganze Zeit, wir wissen aber nicht, wo ihr seid, wir verfremden das und die Leute kriegen nur euren Namen und in der Rückschau vor einem Jahr wartet Jennifer Lawrence am nächsten. Aber okay, aber du kannst ja in der App schon ... Also ich dachte mir, in der App gibchau. Vor einem Jahr wartet Jennifer Lawrence am nächsten.
Aber okay, aber du kannst ja in der App schon, also ich dachte mir, in der App gibst du ein
Jennifer Lawrence und dann
Was? Muss der kurz
Ladebein?
Warum muss der lauter Ladebein?
Und dann
am 4. Mai
2018 standen sie beim
Burger King Mac Drive zwei Autos hinter Jennifer Lawrence. Jennifer Lawrence war in Köln-Sülz? Jennifer Lawrence war in Köln-Sülz am Burger King McDrive zwei Autos vor dir. Und du denkst dir, wow, ich hätte aussteigen können und dir Hallo sagen können. Okay, Jim Carrey. Am 28.09.2018 sind sie mit dem Flugzeug über eine Gebirgskette geflogen, auf der Jim Carrey unterwegs war. Sie waren zehn Kilometer von ihm entfernt. Stephen King. Schalten Sie jetzt das Podcast UFO Premium frei für 2,99 Euro. Stephen King. Am 5. November 2015 waren Sie im Alpinspaßbad. 18.000 Kilometer entfernt von Stephen King.
Das war das Nächste.
Ja, der in Los Angeles in seiner Villa an seinem Roman.
Meistens in seinen Romanen seiner Villa in Los Angeles schreibt.
Geschrieben hat.
Aber als sie dem Spaßbad waren, waren sie am nächsten dran.
So, und jetzt fragst du, wann war Stephen, wann war, wie heißt er denn, ich habe mich nach zehn Sekunden vergessen.
Stephen King? Wann war Stephen King am nächsten an Jennifer Lawrence. Jabba, jabba, jabba, jabba, jabba, jabba, jabba, jabba, und dann Stephen King war beim Burger King zwei Autos vor Jennifer Lawrence. So, und dann hast du auch da alle Verbindungen. Das ist eine geniale App. Niemand kann mir erzählen, wirklich niemand kann mir erzählen, nicht mal irgendwie der Papst persönlich oder irgend so ein Abt oder irgendwie sowas kann mir keiner erzählen, dass man da nicht zumindest mal 20 Minuten drauf rumgoogeln würde. Kannst du mir nicht erzählen. Ich finde auch geil, wenn die App dir nicht eine Top Ten gibt. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Du musst alles abfragen. Die App sagt dir nicht, das sind die zehn Prominenten, an denen du am nächsten oder das war, Stephen King war mal schon mal beim Burger King vor dir, nein, nein, nein, wir wollen wirklich, du musst alles abfragen. Und dann musst du dir selber auf einem Zettel Liste für, ah, Natasha Benningfield, 580 Meter, Jennifer Lawrence, 7 Meter, Leonardo DiCaprio, 260.000 Kilometer im Mond, der war im Mond drin. Und das war das Nächste? Wo ist er sonst? Das ist auch ganz unten. So, und er musste dir selber eine Liste schreiben. Das ist ja genial. Elon Musk. Das ist wirklich genial. Null Meter. Moment. Und dann guckst du über dich und es tropft so ein Blut. Tropfen auf dich. Und du guckst hoch und es ist Elon Musk, der an der Wanddecke langläuft, mit so einem Blutgesicht, wo er so offensichtlich Blut am Mund hat. Ja. Und man denkt, ich wusste, auf eine Art, überrascht mich das gar nicht. Sie blutsaugendes Arschloch. In unserer durchgeknallten Welt wundert es mich auch nicht, dass Elon Musk Blut triefend über mir sitzt. Das, was er nimmt, dieses Abnehmenmittel, was er sich reinpumpt. Das macht ihn zu einem Vampir. Das kann gut sein. Das glaube ich nämlich auch. Das ist Serum. Das ist Serum. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Dass so der Vampirismus zurückkommt, der wieder zurückschlägt. Schaut mal lieber über euch. Ich meine, du würdest natürlich sofort dich selbst googeln. So, du würdest sofort sagen, Stefan Tietze, bin ich unter maximaler Abstand acht Meter. Und dann gucke ich in die Kamera und sage, heute stehe ich wirklich neben mir. Wow! Das Podcast-Supp ist aber eine geile App. Ich glaube, es ist auch gar nicht so schwer. Du musst dir jetzt gar nicht die reichen und berühmten Stalken. Ich glaube, es ist die unrealistischste App-Idee, die wir jemals vorgestellt haben. Wir hatten eine App-Idee, womit man in Zukunft reisen kann, Stefan. Das ist die Unwahrscheinlichkeit. Das Prominente uns den Standort anbieten, Florentin David, Fatskal, Mirko Will. Nein, du stellst eine Horde Praktikanten ein, eine Horde indischer Praktikanten, die einfach Instagram durchfilzen und gucken, Scarlett Johansson, wahr, also jedes Foto, wo war die da, Location, zack, wo ist das, dann Hollywood Hills, Geogester, easy, ja, du schaust aus der Satellitenperspektive, guckst du, wo ist Scarlett Johansson, du brauchst Leute, die Google Maps komplett abfilzen. Aber ist doch verboten. Ja, nicht die Daten, die öffentlich zur Verfügung stehen.
Naja, ich spiele aktuell eine Menge Dota, Dota 2.
Aktuell, ich lasse mich diesen Satz. Naja, ich spiele aktuell eine Menge Dota. Dota 2. Aktuell. Lass mich diesen Satz auseinander. Ich spiele aktuell eine Menge Dota. Ja. Du spielst ja sonst auch schon recht viel Dota. Ich spiele recht viel Dota, das stimmt. Das heißt, jetzt gerade ist es eine exorbitante Menge Dota. Weil ich viel verliere. D-O-T-E-R. Richtig, ich verliere viel und will dann noch mehr spielen, um die Verluste wieder auszugleichen. Aktuell spiele ich einen Helden namens Lone Druid und dessen Hauptfähigkeit ist, der kann einen Bären beschwören. Bist du Mainlane, Secondlane, Safelane. Und der kann einen Bären beschwören und das Besondere ist, man kann dem Bären auch Items geben. Also der Bär ist selber wie ein normaler Held.
Ich bin so gespannt, wo auch was hinausgeht.
Und da musst du halt immer gucken, welche Items hast du auf dem Bären und welche Item hast du auf dem Druiden, weil letzten Endes zählt nur der Druide.
Du bleibst jetzt dabei.
Und da musst du halt immer gucken, welche Items hast du auf welchem Held oder Druiden
und wo ist der Bär, wo ist der Druide selber und die müssen dann immer zusammenbleiben. Ja. Ja, okay, und? Ah ja. Und irgendwann habe ich rausgefunden, dass jemand so unprofessionell ist und zwischendig in seinem Podcast so Raum einnimmt plötzlich und uns auch unterbricht, weil er was sagen will, augenscheinlich passend dann so eine Hobby-Nische einschlägt und dann einfach aufhört und mitten bin, nicht so lustig. Ja, und was ist denn mit den Druiden? Ähm, jetzt habe ich herausgefunden, dass man dem Bären kann man Namen geben.
Ah, der heisst normalerweise Spirit Bear. Also wenn du den einfach beschwörst und dann klickst du den an und dann steht da Spirit Bear. Und jetzt habe ich herausgefunden, weil jeder Bär ist auch ein Item. Automatisch. Was? Why? Also es gibt ja kosmetische Items auch in Dota, dann sehen die anders aus. Das weiß ich. So, wolltest du ja schon mal handeln mit. Anderes Thema. Und das heißt, du kannst verschiedene Bären haben. Der eine Bär sieht aus wie ein Panda-Bär oder wie so ein Schwarzbär, Braunbär, Bär mit einer Jacke an, was auch immer, verschiedene Bären. Und diese Bären kannst du über so ein Itemsystem außerhalb des Spiels auswählen. Jetzt habe ich herausgefunden, dass wenn du dieses Item umbenennst, du kannst dem Item andere Namen geben, dann heißt auch der Bär im Spiel so. Das heißt, wenn du den anklickst, steht dann nicht mehr Spirit Bär, sondern du kannst es selber benennen. Dafür brauchst du aber
einen Umbenennungsmeißel.
Den musst du für 90 Cent
kaufen. Und den habe ich mir jetzt gekauft.
Und du hast deinen Bear wie genannt?
Dann habe ich den Bear umbenannt und
jetzt, ab jetzt ingame, immer wenn
man meinen Bear anklickt, dann heisst der nicht
Spirit Bear, sondern Stefan Tatze.
Das ist sehr schön. Jetzt heißt der ab jetzt immer so. Stefan Tatze. Stefan Tatze. Das ist mein Bär. Das heißt, ich bin jetzt immer in Dota zu zweit unterwegs mit meinem besten Freund, dem Bären Stefan Tatze. Und dein Druide ist nur noch ein Druid. Genau, ja, auf eine Art. Boah, das sei sehr schön.
Ich sag immer, Dota schreibt die schönsten Schichten.
Ich hab meinen Mülleimer Florentin gemacht.
Auf deinem Desktop einfach?
Kann man das umbenennen?
Kann man den Desktop umbenennen?
Ich weiß es nicht, kann man da einfach, ja.
Heißt Desktop bei dem Schreibtisch?
Frisst das Florentin?
Ja, ja, ja.
Bei mir nicht mehr, ich weiß nicht warum.
Sagst du Finder oder Finder?
Finder.
Ich nämlich auch, da wurde ich schon mal gecallt.
Da wurde ich schon mal ausisoliert.
Ja, das Ding ist, glaube ich, man ist relativ alleine.
Ich war sehr alleine damals, als ich mit meinem ersten MacBook Air damals für die Zeitung angefangen habe zu arbeiten.
Da habe ich mir damals auf ein MacBook Air gespart und mir den geholt. Und da ist man recht alleine mit sich in seinen Begriffen. Und da steht Finder und niemand sagt das. Sie öffnen den Finder. Nein, du klickst auf Finder und du bist ein Kind, das ist Finder. Das ist wie Pokémon Gendlemann oder T-Nager. Du hast keine Ahnung, was das ist und es existiert. Oder als ich damals Stephen King gelesen habe, lebte er im Bundesstaat Massachussetz.
Massachussetz.
Was auch wieder komisch tschechisch klingt irgendwie.
Ich meine, Eltern, die Geschichten jetzt, dann sind die da in Massachussetz und alle so,
Massachusetts, Massachusetts.
Du bist unser einziges Kind und du hast uns enttäuscht.
Das ist alles.
Abtreten.
Du bist ein Kind, wir haben ein Kind, wir haben alles auf eine Karte gesetzt.
Und das war es. Kind und du hast uns enttäuscht. Das ist alles. Abtreten. Du bist ein Kind, wir haben ein Kind, wir haben alles auf eine Karte gesetzt.
Und du warst eine Null.
Und du sagst, Massachussetz, ein Idiot.
Eine Null.
Null.
Was willst du werden, Podcaster?
Und du hast gesagt, ja, ich werde Podcaster und ich werde jedes Wort perfekt richtig aussprechen. Ah, nice. Massachusetts. Wyoming. Wisconsin. Ja, das mache ich gerade. Seit der Wahl bin ich wieder im Bundesstaaten-Game drin. Da spiele ich so viele Quizzes. Kennst du den Bundesstaaten? Bundesstaaten-Quizzes? Ich kenne mich nicht mal in Deutschland aus, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Die 16 Bundesländer sind für mich immer noch ein rotes Tuch. Immer noch ein Buch mit 16 Siegeln. Komme ich nicht durch. Nein, nein, stopp, stopp. Ich lasse mich hier nicht demütigen, ich lasse mich hier nicht vorführen, mache ich nicht. Ich lasse mich hier nicht an der Nase. Ne, ne, kann ich nicht. Bin ich zu dumm, bin ich zu dumm, gebe ich zu, ich fühle mich gemobbt, Halt, Stopp, Geografie, nee, Halt, Stopp, Halt, Stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt. Mein Niveau, dein Niveau, hallo, Abstand, es ist so terrible. Komm Nase, wir gehen. Oh Gott, das ist so schrecklich. Ja. Auf eine Art wird es deswegen aber dann doch bei mir funktionieren. Wenn ich jemanden mobben würde und jemanden würde diesen Tanz aufführen, würde ich mich schreiend abwenden. Und auf eine Art ist das ja genau das Ziel. Aber ich finde ohnehin, also ich glaube, nochmal um es aufs Mittelalter zurückzukommen, wo man ja viele auch Abwehr Zaubersprüche hatte. Also du hattest ja Möglichkeiten, dich zu wehren. Also wenn du einer Hexe gegenüberstandest, dann konntest du ja die Finger kreuzen oder hattest du verschiedene Kaputmortem Satanas, konntest du ja verschiedene Abwehrformeln anwenden. Ich glaube, wir reden immer nicht vom gleichen Mittelalter. Ich dachte bislang, wir reden vom gleichen wissenschaftlichen Mittelalter. Doch, ich rede auch vom Mittelalter. Du redest von einem Stronghold-Level oder sowas. Ich rede von wirklich Abwehrformeln, die es auch wirklich gab. Das heißt, wenn dir jemand gegenüberstand, der dir nicht gesusst, der dir suspekt war, kannst du sagen, kaput mortem satanas. Und schon hattest du eine Art Schutzschild. Also die Idee ist ja alt, dass du mit gewissen Formeln Schutzhandlungen vollführen kannst. Und das ist ja nicht schlecht, weil du kannst zumindest was machen. Ich glaube, die haben nur verwechselt Cringe mit so einem, ich weiß nicht, der Dämon wird aus mir rausgesogen. Also wenn ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, eine rothaarige Frau bin, verfolgt von dir, bin zu clever und ich mache allen Männern Angst und so und du stehst vor mir und sagst, kaput mortem und ich sage, oh, unangenehm. Ah ja, okay, du schauderst dich. Und ich schaudere, ob das Cringes und du sozusagen interpretierst das als Exorzistisch. Das kann gut sein. Verdammt nochmal, diese Missverständnisse, diese 500 Jahre alten Missverständnisse, dass man darf jemandem nicht Blut abnehmen, wenn er krank ist, sonst geht es ihm noch schlechter.
dll, so, und genau so, das hilft nichts, irgendwelche Formeln zu
sagen, aber ich finde, solche Formeln helfen ja auch im
Alltag. Also stell dir vor, du hättest irgendwie
keine Ahnung, im Verkehr schneidet dich jemand
und du hast einfach eine gewisse
Fluchformel, eine gewisse,
also jetzt nicht, ah du Arschloch, sondern du hast eine
gewisse
auch einen Satz, der holt dich dann auch
ja, Exxon Carparty, und du
hast einfach so eine Art Formel, die du anwenden kannst, so direkt. Ich glaube, das gibt einfach ... Nissan Qashqai. Ja, klar. So, die man wie so ein Zauber wirken kann. Die meisten Autos heißen auch schon so, wie als wären sie aus der Zeit eigentlich ... Reno Twingo!ingo, kannst du einfach, Mazda, Tsum, Tsum, Kaschkei, Gold, Fox, und aber ich meine, ich glaube, dir geht es besser, weil diese Spruchformeln sind einfach eine Möglichkeit, einfach mal einmal diesen Zauber zu wirken, und dann bist du schon wieder emotional wieder einigermaßen da. Ich glaube, du darfst es nicht in dich reinfressen. Deswegen glaube ich, es sind diese Halt, Stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt. Und dieser Tanz, du führst es um. Dass du das immer noch verteidigst. Ich finde das nicht schlecht. Ich finde das schlecht. Ich finde das nicht schlecht. Ich finde das recht schlecht. Ich fühle mich noch nicht gemobbt. Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, damit, du siehst dir Mobbing auch von neu heran. Ja, das kann natürlich sein. Ich bin jetzt natürlich kein Pädagoge.
Das ist uns allen.
Ja, also ich weiß auch nicht, was
der aktuelle Stand ist.
Du, ich weiß auch nicht, ja,
okay, jetzt muss es auch nicht übertreiben.
Seit 15 Folgen, okay.
Also du musst, ich weiß nicht, was der aktuelle Stand
der Mobbing-Abwehr ist, wie man
das heutzutage macht, was man da den Kindern beibringt
oder ob die überhaupt was in die Hand kriegen.
Revolver.
Du meinst wirklich, dass man Kindern in der Schule Revolver gibt, dass die sich selbst verteidigen? Ja. Warum ausgerechnet Revolver? Also ist das nicht ein etwas, also klar, etwas archaisches, also klar, Schusswaffe, aber ist eine Revolver nicht ein bisschen merkwürdig, also würde man nicht eher so einen Taser oder, sondern du sagst wirklich einen guten alten Revolver. Das ist mein Standpunkt. Ich bin erstmal offen, da kannst du ja debattieren, aber manchmal haben wir erstmal richtig einen Revolver.
Ja, wie in München die U-Bahn wachen früher. Die U-Bahn-Sicherheitsdienstleute in der Münchner U-Bahn hatten Revolver. Die waren nicht nur bewaffnet, die hatten wirklich Cowboy-Revolver. Das kommt ja aus dem Lateinischen. Re für zurück und Volver von drehen. Volvere. Und das Mobbing zurückdrehen oder was kannst du da? Nö, das Magazin kann man so drehen. Gut, das war jetzt aber gar nicht die Frage. Ich weiß, du hast mich gefragt. Ja, ja, nee, nee, hast du mich falsch verstanden? Warum Revolver? Nee, aber warum haben die Revolver? Die Kinder jetzt? Nein. Die U-Bahn, aber da haben sie mittlerweile nicht mehr. Warum hatten die Revolver? Wir haben tatsächlich angerufen, ich hatte ja mal einen Podcast, Fragen beantworte-Podcast, zwei Telefonmässiges außer Kontrolle mit Stefan Natzel, liebe Grüße. Liebe Grüße, finde ich immer noch eine fantastische Idee, ich wollte es gerne mit dir weiterführen. Aber man darf nicht einfach Leute anrufen und aufzeichnen. So, und dann haben wir angerufen bei den Münchner Verkehrsbetrieben und die meinten, ja, das geht zurück auf alte Zeit. Und dann hat der sofort meine Nachfrage vorgegriffen und hat gesagt, nein, es wurde noch nie jemand erschossen. Bitte rufen Sie hier nicht wieder an, Tschüss, Wiederhören. Das heißt, wir hatten über Jahrzehnte ... Bitte rufen Sie nicht mehr an, Wiederhören. Ja, was denn jetzt? Ja, I'm getting mixed signals. Das heißt, wir hatten, in München gab es über Jahrzehnte ein bewaffnetes Sicherheitsteam in der U-Bahn und die haben kein einziges Mal die Raffe abgefeuert. Aber es gibt auch auf der Welt 8.000, 12.000 Atombomben, von denen wurden nach Hiroshima auch keine mehr abgefeuert. Weißt du, was ich meine? Irgendwie habe ich Schwierigkeiten, dir zu folgen. Du meinst jetzt Stichwort Warnschuss oder was?
Nein, nein, die Existenz ...
Also, nur weil die nicht abgefeuert wurden,
können die doch eine Menge ausgemacht haben.
Stichwort Warnung oder Abschreckung.
Also du bist gerade wirklich Probewaffnung, oder?
Nee, natürlich hat das Zweck.
Also natürlich haben Atomwaffen eine abschreckende Wirkung. Die kann man finden, wie man will. Und ich finde, Stahl zieht Stahl an, wissen wir alle. Aber trotzdem kann man die abschreckende Wirkung erst mal objektiv untersuchen. Ja, absolut. Ich denke an Mob an die ... So, ich denke an Mobber. Gibt einfach der Lisa aus der 6b einen Revolver. Glaubst du, die wird noch gemobbt? Glaubst du, die feuert den ab? Nein, die wird den nicht abfeuern. Die kann sie mit ihren kleinen Fingern den Abzug ja ohnehin nicht ... Die kommt ja eh nicht dran. So, das heißt, vielleicht sind es ja auch gar keine echten Patronen. Das sehe ich anders.
Aber mach erst mal, komm, mach erst mal.
Das sehe ich radikal anders.
Ich finde es genau umgekehrt.
Ich würde den wirklichen Atompatronen geben. Also wirklich volle Lotte.
Die ja noch so einen Stromschlag geben beim Töten.
Explodieren in so einer kleinen Atom...
Zum Beispiel.
Okay, ja. Jetzt mal nur offen gesagt.
Wäre es nicht besser, wenn Lisa die
gar nicht abfeuern kann,
sondern nur als Abschreckung. Du hast den
Abschreckungseffekt, aber du hast nicht
die extremen
Sicherheitsbedenken, die damit
einhergehen würden, dass man Kinder bewaffnet.
Super. Das ist nämlich genau, was ich auch
in der globalen Diskussion gerne hätte.
Du hast sozusagen ein Monopol, die kommen dann vom Mond, einfach so, wir sagen, es gibt eine neutrale Instanz, ich dachte nur gerade sinnbildlich, ich fände es schön, aber ich habe es zu weit gedacht, vom Mond herunter. Ah, du hast so ein objektives Komitee, das vom Mond kommt. Einfach um so eine überglobale, also so eine ...
Also wir schicken Menschen auf den Mond, die dort sich fortpflanzen, um neutrale Menschen zu zeugen, die dann neutral auf die Erde zurückkommen. Oder alternativ Schweiz. Das ist die einzige, die am Ende noch die Zündschnur, ich weiß nicht, wie Atombomben funktionieren, aber so das letzte Bauteil, die Zündschnur reinstecken können. Die Lunte. So, und die wissen, das würde gar nie funktionieren. Auch mit Lunte nicht. Oder haben die eine echte Lunte? Die stecken eine rein, aber dann machen sie was raus. Oder was auch immer. Die nehmen ein Bauteil raus, aber die Lunte funktioniert nicht. Ist ja egal. Aber das Bauteil, du hältst ja so kleinen Details auf. Ja, ja, okay. Ich meine so, es gibt eine Instanz auf der Welt, die das abnehmen kann, darf, kann, die das Wissen nur hat für diese, okay, sagen wir, wir erfinden eine neue Bombe, die krasser ist als Atombomben. Atombomben verliehen abschreckende Wirkung, es gibt diese neue, nennen wir sie H-Bomb. Okay, die Hyperbombe. Hat aber nur, und die das erfinden und behaupten, ist halt diese eine Wissenschaftler, krass, der kann eigentlich gar nichts sehen.
So, und der baut Bomben, die nicht sind. Das ist nur die absträckende Wirkung, aber das ist eigentlich eine Hülle. Ja, okay. Die werden noch nicht getestet und so. Aber sau schwer. Die werden getestet und dann gibt es so richtig krasse Bomben, aber es ist alles Bullshit. Aha. Es ist alles so glaubhaft vermittelt, es muss nur glaubhaft vermittelt werden, dass die funktionieren. Ja. Und krass sind das Atombomben, sodass die ihre Abschreckung zwar verwirken und dann die eigentlich krass. So, und die gibst du den Ländern und die sind sehr billig zu produzieren und sehr umweltfreundlich. So, dann baust du davon, dass es aber nur Hüllen, wie Fassaden, so Kulisse. Ja. Ja, warum hast du noch eine Frage? Warum applaudierst du noch nicht? Ach so, sorry, okay. Okay, und dann hat jeder diese Age-Bomb und alle denken, sie könnten sich bekämpfen. Es geht doch nur um die Abschreckung. Es geht doch wirklich nur um die Abschreckung. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Du, kleiner Randnotiz, vielleicht ist das ja bereits so.
Vielleicht hat ja irgendeine, und ich möchte keinen Namen nennen, vielleicht ist irgendeine neutrale Maulwurfsinstanz vom Mond in die geheimen Atomsilos geschlichen, hat da die Schrauben rausgenommen, das ganze Schwarzpulver rausgefüllt, hat dann bei Marshmallow Atom rausgemacht, hat Marshmallows reingetan, damit das Gewicht bleibt, und hat das alles versteckt im Marianngraben. Das heisst, sämtliche Atomwaffen wurden geheim entschärft von einer dritten Instanz, die niemand kennt, so dass die Länder weiterhin denken, sie könnten sich gegenseitig auslöschen und ausgelöscht werden, aber tatsächlich könnten sie es nicht. Ich sage nicht, dass ich an diesem Programm beteiligt war, ich sage nicht, dass ich... Es gibt keine Maulwürfe auf dem Mond, es steht ein Maulwurf auf deinem Rücken. Es ist wissenschaftlich nicht erwiesen, es gibt keine Hinweise. Aber es könnte ja sein. Ja, ich glaube ja, dass alles so viel Bullshit passiert. Ja, du zinkerst die ganze Zeit. Ja, okay. Ui, jetzt bin ich schwindelig geworden vom Blinzeln, ja, ja. Okay, ich glaube jedenfalls, dass da ist viel zu tun. Im Sinne von, da wurde schon viel Quatsch gemacht.
Ja, wir haben noch einiges vor uns. Du hast völlig recht. Und es gibt in dieser ganzen Rüstungsfrage viele offene Fragen, Unterfragen. Ich weiss auch nicht, wie wir hier gelandet sind, aber ich gebe dir völlig recht, in der Rüstungsfrage ist noch viel offen und da gibt es noch wirklich viel zu tun. Es gibt viel zu klären, mehr will ich gar nicht sagen. Viel zu klären, viel zu tun. Viel zu klären in der Rüstungsfrage. Ja, und ich finde, das ist ein schönes Schlusswort für diese dann doch sehr, sehr ernste politische Folge. Aber zur Folge 440, finde ich, passt das auch. Denn wir haben nicht mehr viele Folgen, um diese Probleme zu lösen. Wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, noch 60, 70, 80 Folgen. Dann müssen wir hier Lösungen präsentiert haben, das haben wir uns selbst vorgenommen und ich finde es gut,
dass wir jetzt schon mal die Grundlagenarbeit
abgeschlossen haben und ab nächster Folge
darauf aufbauen können.
Euer Niveau, unser Niveau,
hallo, Abstand,
dass er Flo und ihn will
und Stefan Tietze.
Komm Nase, wir heben ab.
This has been Komm Nase, wir heben ab.